what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch The Last of Us
episode six today of course joined Mama one
and only Andrew Andrew my one and only how
are you Mr Igor 7-Eleven I'm doing great I'm
really looking forward to the continued journey
of Ellie and Joel off to Mordor I'm looking
forward to it I thought you were gonna say
I was looking forward to Henry and Sam's Journey
no I think it's too soon for that I think
I overshot that joke when I did the bill and
Frank one so I I wanted to give that one a
rest for this week maybe next week I'll come
back with that one yeah we'll see what characters
die next alrighty guys well you know the drill
leave a like I got a g fuel in my hand if
you want 20 off G fuel go to the promo code
in the description box reject Nation it's
not a sponsored video but hey it's always
a nice perk that you can get from the real
rejections and I'm always drinking these things
you know subscribe click that notification
Bell because we only got a couple of episodes
left on this show I can't believe it it's
coming around the corner full length Reaction
watch along as we sync up with your own copy
of The Last of Us available for our super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page we cover
several things exclusively over there as well
appreciate everyone who's been here your support
has been not overlooked that sentence could
have been said better let's see what's going
on it's like an hour long let's do it
community
ah winter uh time Jump yep same text from
the game
oh dead animals well that's how it started
in the winters that's why
[Music] Tatanka from Dances with Wolves who
the hell are you take the gun out two fingers
only put it Out Of Reach
he didn't hurt me by the way yeah he's got
a girl with him can I come down no
what did I just say Joe come on they're like
a thousand I need you to tell us where we
are if you got a map while you're lost you
must have missed all the street signs in the
enormous Forest holy we're somewhere here
exactly where and your answer better be the
same as your wives
yeah are you telling me the truth
I love this couple they've got an interesting
Dynamic actually you haven't heard the name
Tommy nope
those in the summer not the Bugs there are
Firefly people they're delivery you got any
advice on the best way west yeah go east if
your brother's west of the river he's gone
laughs
what's going on
[Music] TST just remind you that you're dead
fine he's having a panic attack [Music] if
he did have a panic attack he sure recovered
quick
[Music]
it's always been my favorite in the game when
it's cold weather right oh yeah that's my
favorite section too for sure
ah you are something else Gustavo so good
I'm starving I should have stolen two rabbits
we can get our own rabbits
dude some of these locations are just gorgeous
hmm
oh what just to warm up [Music]
so gross still gross get the reference yeah
you can do anything you want what are you
doing an old farmhouse some land
um cool what kind
quiet [Music] what about you where are you
gonna go everyone else to look what up I read
everything I could in the school library I
think Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin you know
who my favorite is Charlie Ryan Sally [__]
ride best astronaut name astronaut yep it'll
work right the vaccine it's a little late
to start wondering I tried with Sam I knew
he was infected I was wondering if they talked
about it I rubbed some of my blood into his
bite I wanted to save him [Music] get some
sleep dream of sheep ranches on the moon That's
The Last of Us Part 3 is about
laughs still mumbling in your sleep you can't
do things like this but I can because I just
did I'm responsible for you okay then don't
fall asleep I look for tracks I found the
high ground and I kept watch like you taught
me to what can I say man I'm a natural it
sounds more and more like Ellie slowly becoming
indiscernible
that's gorgeous
[Music]
oh he's trying to whistle I'm learning how
to whistle sound like I know how to whistle
seriously though how the [__] do you do
that you should teach me how to hunt not so
sure about the dressing what's the dressing
why don't we take the guts out oh yeah why
do they call it dressing it's like you should
call it undressing because it is it's like
undressing
oh here we go damn ah so that made electricity
no you could have just made something up I
wouldn't believe you foreign
looking for any trouble we're just passing
through out the gun
think five steps back how about we just talk
this through how about you shut the [__]
up okay damn who are these guys I think I
have an inclination but I don't want to spoil
there's no [Music]
oh no don't go to Ellie like I said we'll
just move on now her oh
oh damn that dog's being dick [Music]
ah yes it is the PTSD you're right
[Laughter] oh [__] boy never felt so much
attention just looking for my brother it's
all nothing more
oh
damn is that okay uh yeah what's your name
Joel starts with an m so you're thinking yeah
it is okay all right yeah I couldn't tell
if it was Tommy's people or not that's what
I meant when I said I had an inclination yeah
oh it's so cool seeing live action
holy crap he has yes wow [__] [Music]
um that's a surprise
oh I love it I was not expecting it not at
all be this
Thomas
[Music] let me guess it's the same shirt he
wore Paul's gonna let us know
yeah that is the same jacket from the second
game [Music]
here to save you
[Laughter] [Music]
wow this is this is really surprising it's
been a while since we've had a proper meal
actually I don't think I've ever had a proper
meal this is [__] amazing oh yeah
what
I heard no way I was kids around here don't
usually look or talk like you oh I can't believe
it what is happening right now a bad reputation
doesn't mean you're bad not always at least
he's from True Blood we're grateful for your
hospitality and all would it be nice to have
a moment here maybe just for family
oh Maria is Family actually
oh [__] [Laughter] don't say congrats
congrats
we've settled here about seven years ago just
a handful of us back then welcome to Jackson
all this Open Country out here turkey shoot
I still got my 700 but I found a variable
Power Scope sub MOA has he sounds so Tommy
how do you keep this place quiet carefully
being in the middle of nowhere helps it's
not advertising what we have staying off the
radio snowball fight we draw power from a
dam got that working a couple years ago after
that sewage Plumbing water heaters bites oh
holy [__] this city doesn't exist till
the second game so it's just kind of like
darling to see it all here and then of course
some other characters who won't spoil no wonder
I'm on the council democratically elected
everything you see in our town [__] Collective
ownership so uh communism it is that literally
this is the commune we're Communists no way
a couple months old you want a pet her ah
what's your name Shimmer [Music]
oh whoa dude this is too much well I'll take
Ellie over there if you two wanna catch up
yeah okay
this is such a shock yeah I was not expecting
this to either get over it gotta Reserve so
many things oh yeah we got to be very careful
with what we say afterwards
whatever doesn't seem like you age much you
on the other hand
thanks for still giving a [__] about me
Christmas trees and bake pretty decent setup
recognize where they're at so how's Tess is
fine uh running the kid she's the daughter
of some fire flying monkey muck trying to
find her family somewhere out here so you
know where they might be these fireflies you
know they got a base down at the University
of Eastern Colorado yeah I can't go well because
your wife won't let you no she's the one who
kept you off the radio am I the wrong people
Joe how many things I did tell me those things
that you judged me for come did those things
to Keep Us Alive we murdered people and I
don't judge you for it we survived the only
way we know how uh if you knew the [__]
that I've been through Tommy trying to find
you these last few months I'm going to be
a father what three is a few months long now
[Music] stop oh God but I don't know why [Music]
I guess we'll find out oh man I guess we'll
find out what else am I supposed to say [Music]
dude Pedro is such a good actor just because
life stopped for you it doesn't mean it has
to stop for me
[Music] I'll grab some supplies and be out
of your hair in the morning
damn just that distance between them go searching
for him and then Brothers Living the best
life ever
[Music]
dude does Jackson have a therapist
strayed from the game the music [Music] oh
[Music]
man
no gross foreign
oh are they gonna give us the scene that we
don't actually get in the game
Kevin and Sarah oh she have a kid too before
go ahead try it on it's uh super [__]
purple who's been cutting your hair world-class
salons I was an assistant district attorney
I put bad guys in jail I'm sorry about your
kids it's okay I'm kid just Kevin Sarah was
Joel's daughter yeah we did get it wow there
are clearly things you don't know about Joe
oh like how he used to kill people I know
about that so then you understand my concern
he doesn't do that anymore he stopped killing
people innocent ones and Tommy did it too
you worried about him touche Tommy was following
Joel the way you are now wow maybe I'm smarter
than Tommy no offense oh Dude Love belly be
careful who you put your faith in the only
people who can betray us are the ones we try
interesting I understood where they were going
with that
just met Lucy what did you tell her I was
moving I'm Legit mesmerized right now I'm
just like yeah wow they're doing all this
right now and they're obviously making bold
choices and new choices um wow oh dude look
the whole Workshop yeah you've had people
go that way and come back in all of them what
is this oh she's immune there it is she couldn't
pick it but she didn't get sick I saw her
get bit myself that was months ago months
she's in yeah they really do feel like brothers
she made me swear to take the kid
who was her dying wish what the hell was I
supposed to do we made it as far as Casey
you know she saved my life there from another
kid five years ago I would have destroyed
him yeah but she had to shoot him to save
me because I was too slow and too [__]
deaf to hear him coming I acknowledged it
today I thought that dog was gonna tear apart
oh so far completely there are these moments
where the fear comes up out of nowhere stilted
my heart paralyzed what kind of dreams I don't
know
I just know that when I wake up I've lost
something oh I'm failing him asleep it's all
I've ever done it's failure ouch I'm just
gonna get her killed I know I mean it's what
you took off on me right to make up for the
things we did
yeah you're younger than me you're still strong
you said it yourself you'll come back you
have to take her if anyone else sees those
bites on her what's under her skin she'll
shoot her to the last thing I'll never ask
[Music] I'll take her out of dawn [Music]
I like these enhancements [Music] this is
really all they had to worry about boys movies
[Music] deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt nice bizarre I came here to talk to
you no why are you still here if you're gonna
ditch me ditch me you know I stood up for
you today because I thought
he knows the area better than I do you give
a [__] about me or not of course I do
then what are you so afraid of I'm not her
you know
Maria told me about Sarah and no don't say
another word I've lost people too you have
no idea what loss is
buddy I have cared for has either died or
left me everybody [__] except for you
so don't tell me that I'd be safe with somebody
else because the truth is I would just be
more scared you're right you're not my daughter
and I sure as hell ain't your Dad we're going
our separate ways [Music]
I think it's a brilliant adaptation man yeah
brilliant
how they choose to bring these certain scenes
to life yeah but when to use it and the slight
changes to make brilliant
I thought that was the I was scared I like
that they play more into Joel falling apart
yeah
you can't really say goodbye or something
no I came here to steal one of these horses
and go I would have gave you one
you deserve a choice I still think you'd be
better off with Tom let's go okay okay
there's just things that happened at this
show make me so happy
[Music] there's a place for you here both
of you can I borrow that yeah because Maria
took mine you know
I'm talking about my wife
's Big Brother
oh yeah you ride that horse [Music]
teacher I think so you're flinching the target's
too small I made it bigger than I should have
eject the cartridge
my food just sucks get it yeah deep breath
in slow breath out squeeze the trigger like
you love it gentle steady nice and slow you're
gonna shoot this thing or get it pregnant
it isn't gonna work it doesn't aim right
dick
[Laughter] [__]
wow I think this is the end credits music
in the game
[Music] I like don't want this episode to
end I know right back then there were basically
two main ways of looking at things some people
wanted to own everything and some people didn't
want anyone to own anything at all which one
were you neither I just did my job we were
called contractors it's a contractor [Music]
yeah yeah we're cool everybody loved contractors
great shot don't end please don't end feel
you ending okay
well to the other team are you talking about
football it's called a turnover yes
yes in One Direction I made it in five days
I don't know what Tommy was so afraid of still
time to find out it's your time to find out
contractor
Colorado
wow holy [__] they've done it this way
[Laughter] wow [Laughter] people would live
here and like what go to classes and stuff
yup even though they were adults sort of adults
I think it was just as much about partying
and finding themselves as anything else I
don't want a sheep Ranch actually I mean if
the dealers I can do anything that's the deal
well when I was a kid I wanted to be a singer
why is that funny you gotta sing something
now come on now I'm not gonna laugh you're
already laughing oh will you sing for me later
I'm Gonna Save the [__] world man it's
the least you can do for me fair enough
but they get to see their faces for the shots
like in the game and you're like fracking
behind them are those monkeys monkeys
first time I've seen a monkey first time seeing
a monkey
love this
ah who's on a piece of wall in the game but
that's good enough [Music]
this is happening
we'll see you know how this show can be sometimes
this is coolest there's a vending machine
guys get your health bars
I can list something you make before moving
oh yeah haha [Music]
pulsating ass music rather
yeah at least it ain't clickers yeah no fireflies
either maybe in all that research they turned
into [__] monkeys
that's where they went all the pins lead there
maybe getting ahead of the weather I don't
know hear them [Music]
oh crap we're gonna be getting a cliff hanging
around me yeah we are save it
[Music]
[Music] yes the grab from behind
[Music] oh nicely done
um
ah yep no
[Music]
oh
nice like a western
[Music] is there a monkey on Thomas no
[Music]
Joe
Open Your Eyes Open Your Eyes
without you I don't know where the [__]
I'm going what the [__] I'm gonna do Joe
please
wow [__]
job well done so much to talk about Holy balls
and can't talk about the future of course
yeah we got to be careful what we say but
holy [__] that was amazing the short version
is if you've if you've played both games you'll
know why we were getting excited at certain
things and a certain appearance by what was
clearly a cameo of a character which we won't
go into because yeah I mean I think the the
main presumption that a lot of people have
had even for those I haven't played the game
is like they're just going to do the first
game so to see so much like we've seen like
things that are like oh this is thematically
pulled over from the second game this was
like oh this isn't to happen until the second
game like a lot of this doesn't happen until
like way later this is kind of insane to see
this all brought like the really setting it
up and it it does make sense to me to to cover
some of that and like as much as I love this
episode I I really did love this episode while
it you know was light on action no infected
whatsoever I still I I do there's one criticism
I have that I'm going to reserve uh I will
say it it's not a spoiler criticism there
is one criticism that I have and it's not
like oh the game did this why didn't you it's
something that I genuinely feel like I would
have had even if I hadn't played the game
and I'm curious but I don't know I could be
wrong about that I am curious to see if other
people who haven't played the game will have
this feeling um but regardless as as this
uh episode went I thought it was so great
to keep it focused on the core wounds of both
of these characters and primarily Joel you
know like seeing the this has been a big Journey
since episode one for him to try to get to
Tommy and when he meets up with him like in
in the game itself it's it's relatively light
you know it's not they're like hiding out
at a dam essentially yeah and they got plans
for stuff but this but to see this is a much
more this this hits a more that's why I like
the change because it it emotionally hits
a lot harder when you're like I didn't even
bother to inform my brother about this Safe
Haven we have this civilization we are prospering
in we've got animals like literally this is
the most this this city represents the closest
thing to functioning as normal to before the
outbreak ever happened I'm I'm married I am
having a kid and my brother I didn't bother
to tell about any of this you know and he's
so traumatized by everything he's been dealing
with that he can't it's like you could just
see the the the array of emotions that Pedro
Pascal's going through as all this information
is being received the the anger that can be
ha that can be happening from not being informed
or being excluded from all this information
because like one way to register like my brother
doesn't care to tell me about any of this
oh because you're your wife whatever you know
what do you view me as am I that much worse
of a person and then also the life that he's
having is the life that Joel has repressed
you know because you never thought something
like Jackson could be possible and everything
with Sarah that entire lifestyle is a thing
he has just been in been in denial over and
anything that comes close to the surface of
it just sends him into a panic attack State
and I thought breaking that down in this episode
where he's just coming head on of having to
leave Ellie behind a moment where Ellie could
be killed and he freezes up having to confront
his brother all all that coming to the surface
to then get to a transitional point for this
character where clearly he's being more you
know playful and friendly and open now with
Ellie just you could see it after the whole
horse ride over to Colorado he's just so much
more uh lifelike you know he's smiling and
making jokes and opening up to her I wanted
to be a singer and all that even different
than the beginning of this episode so I thought
like as a because while they do they do skip
over a lot in the game like they do like don't
get me wrong they they do there's some stuff
I would have liked to have seen the whole
damn sequence yeah yeah yeah I mean this was
a nice surprise even the you know the escape
from the University yeah it was much more
shorter in this version yeah whereas in in
the game it is very much like you have to
go through some bad guys and then when he
gets uh injured he gets like throw he gets
knocked through a window and it lands on him
he falls off the guard rail and then lands
on a like a a pipe thing that's sticking out
yeah okay yeah it wasn't a window yeah I just
remember that I'm up on the floor and he fell
which I'm sure in like a real life live action
if we might be like would you have survived
there yeah well I thought that came too but
yeah yeah that's what I mean um but it's much
more intense having to like really help him
to escape where here they take a much more
subdued approach uh to it um but that's not
even my complaint uh but before I even say
what that is Andrew first I want to give myself
a little pat on the back I made that joke
about the very beginning in my intro where
I said you know they're on their journey to
Mordor and then we got a couple fake outs
at the ending where you've seen Return of
the King you know exactly what I'm talking
about that movie's the king of fake outs when
it comes to endings I agree with that just
the amount of traveling too feels like very
Lord of the Rings yeah yeah well of course
of course I just meant that it's just interesting
I make that point when an episode has multiple
endings it felt it felt like but uh not a
complaint right just an observation but I
agree with everything you said I felt like
you know the changes that were made here or
not even changes so much like the more it
was just a lot more emotionally drawn out
and a lot more dramatic like yes you did feel
that Joel was afraid of you know being that
protector that Ellie needed in the game but
here it's a lot more dramatic a lot more drawn
out especially that scene he has with Tommy
like I really felt a lot more emotionally
invested in that see not that I don't love
that scene in the game it's really good in
the game but it's a lot more lighter in tone
whereas this it's a lot more dramatic you
feel like because they set up the whole PTSD
moment it really LED lens Credence to the
moment that we get here and it's just again
just to clarify you're talking about when
he when Joel does open up and is asking um
yeah yeah yeah Greg listen great sorry I was
distracted myself
but yes no I just I appreciate that and I
got it at everyone who acted in the especially
Gabriel Luna damn that man just sounds so
much like it's just it's ridiculous I'm almost
think like Jeffrey Pierce is dubbing from
but I know he's not but it's just so much
it's really incredible but I really gotta
tip my cap to Pedro Pascal and and belly she
is the level of depth that she goes to when
it comes to emoting and just the uh the emotional
balance that she has as an actress it's just
incredible like the scene for instance just
at the very end where Joel Falls over straight
out of the game and you know you do get Ellie's
pleas of Joel trying to wake up in the game
but again here it's I like that they draw
it more out like you really feel it here yeah
in the show uh like you know where she starts
crying and like saying I don't know where
to go I don't know what to do and again that
was in the game but again it's just drawn
out it's more dramatic here and I really feel
it you know emotionally to my core a lot more
here which I appreciate and again yeah this
this episode no clickers no infected I mean
a little sad about that always whenever we
don't get infected but again with what we
were dealing with from you know Joel's perspective
in terms of the PTSD yeah they did you know
again that was touched upon in the game where
he had a fear of you know not being able to
protect Ellie but again the way it's portrayed
here by Pedro Pascal I mean just again the
level of depth that he goes through as an
actor is just it's really really incredible
and I just didn't think he was able to go
to that level and I just really appreciate
it and again just seeing Jackson I was not
expecting that in a certain possible character
or not possible we a certain character that
we did get that was awesome I thought there
was going to be another one that I think you
know who I'm talking about that we didn't
get uh but that was really cool that they
did that um and yeah I know this episode I
mean if you're if you're a fan of the game
I really feel like most fans of the game are
really gonna love this episode give or take
a couple little things that they skipped over
in terms of the dam and the University of
Eastern Colorado but for the most part and
obviously the way they figured out that they're
at St Mary's uh well said it in Utah rather
I'll just say that the fact that they found
that out on a map it was a little different
in the game where they found out on a voice
recorder from a guy one of the doctors or
something uh the fireflies that was still
uh that had died there not a big deal I don't
think that's going to bother too many gamers
so I think this what I loved again about this
episode is the expansion uh the the the good
changes that they made but also like you're
gonna in my opinion you're gonna appease uh
Gamers with this episode but you're also gonna
piece people who haven't played the game in
just like good damn television and I think
this episode really did a good job of that
when you talk about an episode that is more
on the dramatic side and less on an action
side when you're thinking of something in
a post-apocalyptic world and I also to got
to give Credence and and uh applaud to the
the cinematography and the locations in this
episode and the way they use the snow in the
background and all in the foreground and all
that was so damn beautiful I mean these locations
were freaking amazing it had a great sense
of atmosphere throughout the entire episode
and uh we got to hear more of the the tracks
from the from the games as well uh yeah I
thought this it's helped build out the world
even more which was excellent and you know
I I do want to speak I do really want to speak
on from like game comparison in a way in a
way that's very complementary to the show
because the there are certain scenes in here
that are yeah that that scene is in the game
but when it occurs in the game is very different
and the placement I'm not just talking because
I had like a bunch of other stuff or something
like that it's the lead into the scene is
so different that it re-contextualizes a lot
of the scenes like for example that moment
where you're talking about with um where where
Tommy learns about Ellie that happens pretty
early much earlier on when when he does reunite
with him at the dam and and in the game he's
not even searching for Tommy you know he's
not even like looking for him right no they
were looking for Tommy they were nobody left
for he was looking for Tommy for to get to
the fireflies right yeah well because he wanted
to drop Ellie off at Tommy so he could take
her to the fireflies yeah but like I mean
in the in the game it's it's more so they
they have had a falling out of sorts correct
whereas in the show he's like I haven't heard
from my brother I'm worried about him I need
to refined him correct that's the difference
with with this correct he enters here worried
like I don't know what's happened to him and
I'm afraid he might be dead yes so they even
have that scene that's not in the game at
all with uh that Native American couple at
the top of this which I thought was a great
scene by the way um but when he does tell
him you know they have that that conflict
first where he doesn't open up to him or they
get into a fight and then he eventually tells
him and whereas in the game he He Still Remains
a lot more hardened but gets a little soft
here it's it boils down to he feels like he's
not good enough I feel like she will die in
my hands which I think adds just so much more
weight to this character development of a
guy who's having to overcome so much rather
than I'm just more than just I'm afraid of
connection which he all which Pedro Pascal
already brings to this character it's a fear
that he will repeat the same mistake that
happened with Sarah which I thought made it
so much more impactful and where to place
it in this episode and with the context of
how they built Jackson he's gonna be a dad
I think makes him telling Tommy and asking
that favor of him so much stronger um and
even the scene where Joel and Ellie uh they
where they do have that confrontation where
he's like you're right you're not my daughter
that whole scene so much of that is like I'm
like I'm sure most of that was just like work
dialogue from directly from the game yes it
was but when that occurs in the in the game
it's it's the lead into that is very different
much different whereas here it's a lot more
of a solemn like we're gonna say bye she learns
about it and then you know she's like like
her chilling in a room that's that's not the
case in in the game right and it emphasizes
the dramatic moment more and because you had
the scene prior where you're seeing that he's
not just being some hardened [__] who's
who's like I just no I I I gotta treat her
like she doesn't matter to me where he because
I don't think in the game he doesn't tell
her I care about you does he tell does he
say that line that's the part that stood out
to me where he says do you even care about
me and he says of course I do is that in the
game that's the part that stood out to him
if it is I'm not remembering right now but
I I don't recall that in the game because
other than that line I'm like everything else
sounded like it was from the game for the
most part everything else was yeah from the
game because he's coming in to that scene
already much more vulnerable versus how he
was in the game so you know like when he gets
hurt by what Ellie's saying then his defense
mechanism Rises back up and says that and
I I like the way the context is displayed
here a little bit more actually because some
have criticized the Pedro Pascal portrayal
I've heard some of it of being being a little
bit softer um yeah no he's not as much of
a hardened [__] he's definitely got more
of the depression wearing in his eyes people
skipped over the scene where he was beating
the crap out of that guard with uh yes but
I don't know I I like I really love what they
do uh for I really love what they do like
the criticism that I had was I wish because
because of the fact that what you because
one thing that this show does that's really
cool to me because a lot of those moments
where you see us getting excited like when
they're on the horse that you're still doing
you're still doing gameplay in those scenes
when you're playing the game right so it's
a tracking shot of of behind so you're not
actually it's not a cut scene but the dialogue
is still happening whereas here they get to
treat it more like a cutscene where you can
actually focus in on the characters you could
see their faces see their reactions so I think
that's really cool that they're taking moments
where the dialogue change happens during game
play and you get to make a whole scene out
of it yeah yeah so you can really focus on
the actors and I think it's really cool very
true uh but with that so much of the bonding
between Ellie and Joel happens during the
gameplay and not necessarily cutscenes and
I wish we had more of them bonding together
but before getting to this moment where they
might split apart that's the one part of this
that even if because so much of that bonding
happened off screen that all happened was
in that three-month period you know that we
didn't get a z and what will help make up
for that is the fact that I really felt like
the actors Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsay they
really brought their a game and built whatever
that three-month history was together because
you can see their relationship changed you
can feel that the relationship change and
the way they interact has really changed so
yeah I like I buy it I just feel like I I
still I still do feel that even if I didn't
play the game I'd be one I'd be left going
I wish we got to see them bomb more before
we get to the episode where they might split
apart you know yeah I I get what you're saying
I mean I think this episode really nailed
like again not the cut scenes but the scenes
where you are actually in control you're seeing
more of the back of their heads and then you
have that dialogue where they are bonding
so they really did nail that in this episode
so I mean no I get where you're coming from
I mean I just think their performances have
been just so freaking good that that hasn't
bothered me as much but if obviously if they
had expanded a little more you know with them
bonding I'm not gonna complain I'm always
down for some belly and Joel so I mean ideas
the last episode they had just started really
bonding yeah you know what I mean no I I get
what you're saying I'm not saying I disagree
I'm just saying it hasn't I I guess it hasn't
bothered me as I'm not saying it's bothering
you like crazy or anything but it it hasn't
been a thing that's an issue for me but I
I get where you're coming from I can see where
you're saying and again if they would have
had more scenes like that I'm not I mean heck
yeah I'm down for it for sure so but that's
I think that's a very fair criticism that
that you make I do also really like that scene
that they had with Maria and Ellie I thought
that was a great expansion in scene because
we didn't get a we I mean at least I I mean
I don't remember in either game where we heard
that Maria had a child and lost that child
so just getting the expansion yeah so getting
the expansion on her character and then also
seeing the way that she defends Joel like
it just like again that those inner the interaction
that you had with Maria I just I really appreciated
that conversation but I appreciated more was
how she was defending Joel so quickly and
just like again just how sharp she was in
her into like that just that like that's Ellie
it was just to the T and again we'd never
gotten that scene in the game so that's what
I love about the show and I think you were
just when you're like this is just how you
do an adaptation like they just know where
to pick their poisons when it comes or rather
their strengths rather when you know they're
doing like a shot for shot thing with dialogue
or imagery visuals you know when it comes
to the game or stuff that they're expanding
upon and I mean they're just really nailing
it on the head for man again I really like
that that uh expansion we got with uh Maria's
character when she was cutting her hair which
kind of an Easter egg to her cutting her hair
but um well you know actually the thing about
the kid if I could interrupt for one second
yeah which I think is neat because so much
happens in a world like this is there's the
the trauma bonding element yeah they're all
kind of experiencing a universal trauma bonding
yeah because of the the thing and both but
then uh but Sarah I imagine in a lot of ways
was like a daughter to Tommy too so of course
of course um but the addition to that because
that scene happens whereas like Serato uh
Maria told me about Sarah but that happens
off screen in the video game so you know the
second they went from someone that's when
I said like are we gonna get that scene I
was like oh we're gonna see how Maria told
him and I think it makes more sense because
it always did kind of uh I wouldn't say rub
me the wrong way but whenever that came up
in the game I was like why would that just
come up in conversation with Maria and Ellie
I mean I get what you're saying but didn't
they just to defend the game they Joel and
Tommy were off for a good 15-20 minutes so
we don't know what was exactly talked about
obviously now we do but I I I get where you're
coming from now yeah no I I just I feel like
that's such a we need to see that conversation
we need to see that little bit because even
here Maria doesn't go into this whole story
yeah yeah she's not going you know like oh
Sarah died in the uh day of outbreak or something
like that and you know she just realized she
had a slip of one one one sentence and was
like never mind yeah well also I like the
guard rails too on Maria like just being so
protective of Ellie because again like you
talked about just it's such a traumatic like
everyone's gone through some kind of uh you
know trauma so I think you make a good point
there and by the way you knew that uh I'd
get a little off topic uh you know that Tess
also had a husband and a child that they didn't
you knew about that too or no um yeah I thought
they mentioned that in the show oh did they
okay because uh if if they did my fault for
free game but apparently they had a deleted
scene where uh they should was like a flashback
where she shot her husband oh I know that's
where I heard it yeah there was a delivery
yeah getting all my information yeah I'm getting
crosswired here yeah yeah so but yeah my mind
went to that just because we were talking
about characters and their kids and all that
stuff in the drama but yeah getting back to
this episode though like I said if if you're
a big fan of the game I think there's a lot
in here to appease you notwithstanding the
damn stuff that they that they completely
cut out obviously but I I don't think it was
honestly I don't think that was really necessary
that was more of just action sequence and
the dramatic part from the dam that they needed
they just moved it over to Jackson which again
we got some really good previews of stuff
and obviously I'm allowed to say this we got
to see Shimmer they even mentioned by name
so as you saw from our reaction and uh again
just uh would have liked the University of
Eastern Colorado a little bit longer sure
but again it's not something that that's just
the gamer in me but uh I I thought it was
completely fine with the pacing of what they
were doing in the episode so yeah overall
I I really dug this episode it's probably
one of my favorite episodes just I mean just
from the atmosphere the performances from
Bella Ramsay and Pedro Pascal like just really
elevated this episode to another level on
top of all the things we got previewed to
us um but just and also too just the moments
we got from the game that were more drawn
out more emotional in this one I mean I just
I really appreciated this episode a lot well
I like seeing how their bond works with them
learning how to hunt together or learn how
to shoot yes yeah seeing these skills at Le
because even though um I mean she was taught
some stuff in Federer school yeah uh it's
not a big deal to say that though I'm like
I sometimes I forget like did the show mention
this or not um even if they didn't mention
it yeah something I mean and Marlene even
said in the first episode like that I brought
I sent you to federal school yeah you can
you can say that but yeah in federal school
like she'd learn how to shoot but not nothing
like a rifle yeah yeah um to that degree right
so seeing seeing that ooh next episode must
be yep where we get some flashbacks too I'm
thinking that too oh there's three episodes
three episodes oh my God yeah it's either
the next episode or it's episode eight it
it could be episode eight but uh yeah yeah
I think it might be episode eight with the
flashback that you're talking about that if
you're a gamer you know exactly what I thought
they really explore that because I think we
know what's happening again without going
to spoilers we know what's gonna happen in
the next episode so um but yeah I mean they
go through I do think that sometimes they
skip over some I sometimes I am I I do get
the impression oh they just saw those Hunters
up but then again it's a lot less Hunters
there's like four Hunters um sorry I guess
there's a scenario yeah I I actually you know
what that might just be the gamer me too of
like because because not it's not the same
thing as the sniper in the last episode where
you're like how do you just get around that
seriously they could have had they could have
had such a good moment for attention here
yeah even if I'd hadn't played the game I
would have had that complaint but but I agree
but here you know they see all they see this
Hunters down there or whatever there if you
see them down there and they just like are
able to get to their horse pretty easily you
know and to me just even as a show viewer
I would have been like oh that would have
been some cool moments to ring out some tension
because I think I think a part of a part of
Last of Us the world that I love about it
is the having to sneak around and then kill
some people and you know having to be really
cautious and I like the stealth stuff and
I think this show is kind of absent like keeps
that not really present in the game in the
show which kind of that's one element that
I'm like I wish I wish that was here there
are still moments of tension in the show for
sure but there are other parts where in like
that what you just specifically highlighted
that that criticism I will completely agree
with you on that kind like with the sniper
and then exiting uh Eastern Colorado and then
obviously we skipped a whole tunnel sequence
in that last episode but well even if even
if it was just a show yeah like oh that would
have been such a good moment to ring out like
I would have I would have been such a good
tension sequence I agree but it goes by quick
but that moment with the dog where she where
it was about to that's good yeah that was
great tension it's like now I want to see
that with people and dogs don't even come
into the second game second game yeah I mean
we see the one dog in the uh in the first
game when they're at the dam and Tommy says
I forgot the dog's name um I mean the dog
wasn't we didn't see him sniffing or anything
but that was it I mean the other additional
scenes that I I think there's a lot of great
addition because a lot of the scenes are there
are scenes in here that are like that the
whole scene with the dog sniffing that's not
in the game and I think and I think the enhanced
and none of this stuff with Joel getting emotionally
triggered would become stilted you know um
which uh where he get where he does get Frozen
when the trauma gets too strong for him yeah
that's that's not in the game either and I
think those are wonderful wonderful add-ons
to do to your show and I agree I think that
there's a lot of see the thing is for everything
that they don't provide for me from the game
they add something else in here that I'm like
I love that right I love that scene that they
did and it's usually just a character scene
it's not even like they gave me a different
action scene it's some character scene it's
interesting you say that it's like you did
the hard part the character stuff the right
dialogue now just come up with attention no
action scene because that's the funny thing
is most video game adaptations just try to
do the action yeah and they don't do the character
stuff but I'm like but they're doing the most
important part because last of us is really
known for its story and granted we did get
an amazing action sequence in the last episode
where the bloater and all the effects and
The Collector scene in the second episode
is phenomenal yeah yeah for sure absolutely
we've gotten some incredible action sequences
that have been filled with tension but I agree
with you it's those little moments where it's
like it just adds another layer and again
this is not us saying we hate obviously we're
obsessed with the show it's just something
that we just elevate it to another level to
the stratosphere which it's pretty much already
there as it is but no like in terms of characters
and all the expansions and that kind of stuff
they've taken this to another level for sure
I think it's only distracting when like I'm
not distracted if you just skip over it like
with Bill all the [__] with Bill it doesn't
bother me because they just completely skip
past it yeah so I'm not even really thinking
about it I'll be thinking about it when I'm
like oh [__] we're about to go into that
oh they just kind of like really shorten the
[__] out of that yeah and that's when
I get distracted I agree as someone who's
played the game um and because then I have
to like kind of check my thought process like
is it just because because like that scene
here at the when they're when the hunters
show up I'm like oh that's a really tense
ass game moment and it's it's scary and intense
at least in that big dramatic moment right
and then here they literally exit Within
I don't know how long it took like in the
actual context of the TV show but in screen
time it was 10 seconds for us and there was
no tension in terms of the exiting we're in
the game like again even if we're not Gamers
but just pointing out in the game it it takes
a good while to get out of there yeah because
even finding like the lab stuff you know you
have to really search the building forever
yeah and I'm cool they skipped that yeah that's
cool that's fine I'm cool with that because
it is kind of just like how do you how do
you find all this [__] again you guys
are like a hassle yeah but but here yeah it's
only just it only it only kind of like pings
that part of my brain when I'm I agree with
when the show is like about is telling but
it basically like I think they delivered that
in the second episode yeah where with the
clickers yeah with the clickers because there
is that whole sequence of the clickers in
the game and I'm like oh they're delivering
it but they're doing it differently and they're
making it their own and I do I do get that
itch but again though they're nailing telling
the things that matter more right right of
course of course we could just sit here and
only focus on the on the Praises but you know
like that's what John and Tara are for on
the because they haven't played the game so
they're here to not even be concerned about
it but I agree with you even if we if we hadn't
played the game I'd still probably say like
okay like we got there pretty fast yeah they
got out of there pretty fast or yeah no I
I agree with you I think it's a valid constructive
criticism but again like you said they're
nailing them the most important things so
that the characters the emotional depth and
obviously like I've always said from the beginning
if you can nail Joel Nelly everything else
is just icing on the cake from there and yeah
to me for the most part they have completely
nailed Joel Nelly thus far yeah and there's
two people who actually really love the last
of us too where I know that it's a very debatable
game for a lot of people um I was over the
moon about seeing you know that there's a
divide wait everyone doesn't love Last of
Us Part Two it's not the same level of overwhelming
love but everyone was obsessed with it the
exact same way as the first game it's not
divided anyway I thought did you know where
you were it's a real thing yeah it's a problem
for people but uh yeah for me I was like I
I was way over the moon and then seeing that
one oh my God yes like that is a pure Easter
egg oh my god oh for sure it is the purest
of Easter eggs because only if you've played
the second game you know any idea who your
person was you know and it wouldn't even be
a spoiler for me to say the name um but I
just won't no we're better than that people
we don't wear t-shirts that spoil game well
oh sorry we'll we'll wait till we're reacting
to heavy spoilers videos yeah we'll let we'll
let Paul do the the spoiling for us and then
we'll we'll expand upon uh certain cameos
and other foreshadowing things for the future
and it is kind of cool to because I didn't
realize that they because they've obviously
changed the ethnicity of Maria right if you
have like a lot of the characters here um
well just like a few Joel and the topic okay
Sarah but uh yeah when but it was kind of
interesting to pick up on like because I had
no idea that they that they uh I didn't even
think like who's playing Maria I didn't even
think about that for a second and but when
she started that might be that might be Tommy's
boyfriend once you said to I mean I was already
thinking that but when she said is this who
I think it is I was like uh this is yeah I
was thinking exactly that's who I think it
is today I love her work I've seen every season
of True Blood I love her work on True Blood
that's the only thing I'm really familiar
with her on and I I think she's phenomenal
on that show and so to see her here on another
HBO show gets me really excited and she does
bring the the pr because Maria is like and
it's like a like a warm presence but also
a Stern presence yeah I agree and one last
thing that I want to mention too I really
like how it was just a really quick scene
but I liked that they were talking about how
the town kind of formed and she was on the
council and all that because I I know you're
you're I mean I'm a huge fan of the second
game you're a little bit bigger of the fan
than I am do you remember that though that
being talked about in the second game I don't
know man you remember like more trivia stuff
better than I do this is true I just I don't
remember I mean I remember knowing that her
father and her started up the town but I don't
remember talking about the whole Council and
all that I know I knew Maria was in charge
I remember that yeah I didn't really commit
to memory Maria facts I thought she was your
favorite character in the game dude come on
he just comes and goes in the game um so either
way I thought that was a nice little introduction
to the town and expansion and just you know
how it all got started and what what they're
doing there so yeah no this this worked for
me on on uh I still I still loved it I I love
I love the hell out of it and then for things
that I thought were missing from not having
um getting more time with um Ellie and Joel
to bond prior I really feel like that scene
would have just hit a million times harder
if if we had seen them bond together a little
more I no dude I know I totally I get where
you're coming from it it hasn't bothered again
not saying it bothers you over the moon but
I agree with you would have been nice to get
a few more of those scenes for sure yeah get
a little more time to breathe with that but
I'm Still Loving what we've got that's the
ironic part it's like I still I still love
the [__] out of this episode like I I
love this episode I didn't want it to end
but I'm not gonna lie to you I did notice
more in this like my brain was telling me
during this like we are getting so many more
scenes in this episode particularly of not
only them you know forming a bond with each
other like that's obvious but just the the
scenes where you're in control and again the
cameras to the back of your head and they're
just talking like those are some of my favorite
moments in the game and you're not even there's
no action happening in the game and you're
still in control but nothing's happening but
dialogue and bond building like those are
literally some of my favorite moments in both
games when moments like that are happening
so again I I totally get where you're coming
from I I would definitely like to see more
scenes like that for sure but so far I've
still loved what we've gotten me too because
I really thought the actors at least brought
the history for the three-month Gap yeah and
and that was another thing too that I think
Pedro Pascal and Gabriel Luna like they really
nail that Bond ship that they have as others
like you really feel the history those two
have with each other they have such electric
on-screen chemistry together when it comes
to them playing Brothers with each other and
just the way like how he broke down in front
like I I just I I mean I've had conversations
like that with my brother so like I could
totally relate to that and I just I felt that
between the two actors and just again this
show is so damn well made on all facets it's
just it's really impressive and the thing
with that moment too of the Christ it was
me I could talk about every every because
there's not a scene here I didn't like that
yeah that's the thing is like I just wish
I had some other scenes yeah but the with
the but even the way he was doing the crime
scene because like there's many ways an actor
can choose to do something like that and I
like that it wasn't just like him bawling
because Joel this even this interpretation
wouldn't ball like he would be fighting he
was doing everything he can to not really
cry you know so I like that it was more of
like he's fighting tears it gave me to a foreshadowing
of a future moment which I know you know what
I'm talking about but we'll talk about it
off camera in terms of the crying yeah yeah
yeah I know I know exactly what he's talking
about um but yeah uh a great great episode
uh this left me over the moon uh at the end
of the day I was still left over the moon
I think that was part of the one of my favorite
parts of our reaction to this episode is like
don't and please I mean I always feel that
way when we're getting towards the end of
all these episodes and obviously to me at
least this particular episode no it was really
do not end yeah please yeah I know like in
the last episode when you kept you you were
probably thinking like more Kathleen scenes
more cats everyone was thinking that all right
guys well thank you for being here uh be sure
to subscribe three more episodes to go and
uh I can't wait for this man I can't believe
that that is as a gamer because I I know that
doesn't really I'm sure I really do wonder
what I mean imagine it's still effective for
audience members who haven't played the second
game but for people who are fans of the second
game I'm like wow what a what a treat oh yeah
I couldn't believe it I couldn't believe it
either that was not this whole experience
I was like this is a shock most shocking and
also too one other thing one as much as I
love HBO Max and and Neil druckman and all
of them I've been a little bit sad that they've
been kind of spoiling some preview stuff like
for next episodes and stuff so it's I'm just
glad like it allows us to put things in thumbnails
then when they do that that's true and then
I can go well they're showing it that's true
that's true that's true so I was really like
genuinely happy like not knowing anything
about this and like oh my God not at all expecting
that alrighty well thank you guys so much
for being here um I had a great time and hey
let's end this with a lucky Pig
Gabriel Gabriel honor Gabriel Luna we are
shouting you out today Gabriel I hope that
this well Valentine's Day has passed but I
hope you had a banger of a Valentine's Day
I hope it was romantic or at least frisky
and if it wasn't that's even better trust
me you don't want to be trapped it's like
having a constant handcuff on you it's disempowering
and emasculating so she doesn't make us these
foreign videos nor does she watches frame
of them so I'm safe real
if she asks I love her and I will always be
obedient to her at all costs um but Gabriel
I consider you to be a very kind soul your
name like Gabriel don't you just gotta automatically
assume they're a nice person I've never met
a dick named Gabriel dude for sure I mean
I mean what's Gabriel Byrne was evil in end
of days but we got Gabriel and the actor I
know but I'm saying I'm saying we got Gabriel
and the Patriots one of my favorite characters
Heath Ledger so there you go yeah there you
go man so and Gabriel Luna here is gent as
well and Gabriel in the dictionary means God
is my strength holy crap well you know what
Gabriel you're our strength we don't need
God we just go to you so thank you for being
you hope you have a great rest of the 2023
and if you're single go out there mingle and
if you're taken go be shaken and bacon with
her I don't know I did that Justin I'll see
you buddy
oh